hey all it's energy couch here and this
time today's a video we're going to be
going over how to create machine
learning models using big data
but first i have a huge announcement
this will be my last tidy tuesday video
for the series and
uh will be the end of my regular
scheduled content
but
um i'll kind of talk more about the
details towards the end of the video
but first let's actually open up a our
markdown document and i'm going to call
this tidy tuesday
big data
all right and we're going to load in a
few packages set
um
a few packages so we're going to load in
the idverse
i'll make this a little bit bigger
load in the tidy verse
id models
how do you predict
fine tune for training some models
a sparkler
for creating our models using um spark
as a back end and also the dbi package
um
we're also going to load in our options
and i always do tidy models dot dark is
equal to true
and lastly we can also load in our data
set which is a customer churn data set
that we've used in the past for some of
my other videos okay
so
if we look at our customer data set or
our customer return data set we have a
customer id some
some general attributes of the person
um some monthly total charges and
whether they actually turned or not
um if we actually look at the
missing values
let's say is.n a and then we do like a
call sums
we can see that there are 11 missing
values so
considering that we have about 7 000
rows i think it's fair to say that we
can just drop those missing values or
drop the samples with the missing values
so let's actually do some data cleaning
um i'm going to mutate across all the
columns
where
the variables are a character
and i'm going to say as dot factor
right
now everything is a factor
if they are
um a character
and then lastly we're going to do the
drop n a
and that'll drop these missing values so
we're going to say
create convert
features to factors
and drop missing values
um i could do a
factor thing for the senior citizen but
senior citizen is actually a uh
is a uh like a one hot encoded variable
already or a dummy variable so we don't
have to do
a lot of data manipulations to it
so when we're thinking about big data um
we're also thinking about like having a
large volume large velocity you know a
lot of samples but
one of the main problems when we're
facing big data when we're making some
predictive models is that oftentimes the
data that we're you know trying to use
can't fit into memory which is like the
amount of ram we have
now we can always set up you know
different environments using like cloud
computing and stuff like that but
oftentimes we might want to think about
how we can do it like in the database
right since databases have a lot of
power behind it
and
you know ideally it'd be kind of nice to
just have it run out in the database
instead uh so that way we don't have to
use it on like our nice little laptop so
we have at our office
um and there are a lot of ways we can do
this
uh for me i don't use a lot of big data
programs so like a lot of common ones i
think are like hadoop and spark so like
i think hadoop
hive hadoop slash hive and then spark um
but for me
uh i really don't use a i really don't
uh face a lot of big data challenges but
i often want to make some predictions in
database because oftentimes you know
we can if we have a model that's pretty
good and we can put it as a essentially
a query then we can have the databases
do all that work you know we don't have
to worry about dependencies with r we
don't have to create our docker
containers or stuff like that we just
create our query give it to someone have
them schedule it out
and we can go on from there so this is
the first method we're going to do which
isn't really about big data but it's
about how to make you know
predictions in database using machine
learning models with the tidy models
framework
so we're gonna just do a classic uh
train and test split we'll say initial
splits a df
i'm going to deselect the customer
id
and we'll say strata
is based off of churn
and then we'll create our trained data
so training
model splits
and then our k-folds data will be using
our train data oops
cv so train
data
okay
um now we're going to do a kind of a
typical run um in this case when i know
that i want to make a model that's going
to be in a database i'm trying to think
about you know what are some nice strong
models
but also that aren't too large so
oftentimes when we're thinking about
using machine learning models we want to
do like you know a lot of tree based
models but the problem with tree based
models is that you know oftentimes we're
using like random forest or actually
boost
and like with random forest we're gonna
be creating a lot of trees and each tree
is essentially going to be like kind of
a query so that can get very large so we
have if we have a random forest model
being trained to predict a customer
churn you know oftentimes that that
model might have like 500 trees which
can actually come raising issues with
the you know
the query um since the query can be too
large and you can run into weird system
errors but that being said i like to do
mars models when i'm thinking about
doing
um
a sql model so i'll just say num terms
equals tune
uh prod degree or the you know the
interaction term
we'll tune it and we'll say set mode
is a classification
we'll set our engine to be
earth
right
cool and then we have to do a slight
recipe so we'll say rec
recipe
turn
data is equal to train
data um and then we'll say step
dummy
all new all nominal
predictors
right so if we do a prep
and juice
oops
juice
juice
juice we can see that it's created our
dummied
variables
right
um and then we still have our our stuff
so obviously with our most of our uh our
numerical variables or our continuous
variables is ten-year monthly charges
and total charges and then we have our
other our other variables stuff like
that
okay so now let's actually tune our
model and if we notice um i loaded in
the fine tune package which can allow us
to do different tuning methods that'll
kind of select our parameters for us so
i'll say mars res
tune sim
anneal
give it our mars model our recipe our k
folds
data and then our metrics
i'm just going to say we want to
optimize or evaluate our each iteration
by roc aoc
okay
so now um it'll be training
um
and we should be able to see yeah
some little dialogues right here we'll
just kind of wait
and see what it looks like over here
and i'm going to do a
autoplot and say rs res
so we can do some pre
tuning
we'll also create
um some models or some just um some
pre-coded stuff right now
so
you know we might want to do show best
mars res and we'll see the roc aoc
and then we'll actually create our final
model
which will be
this one right here
and we'll just wait just a little bit
so often times i think we hear a lot
about big data but
for me from like a basic you know data
science workflow i don't think you
actually will see a lot of big data
unless your job is you know has that
type of data in its field so you know if
you're doing a lot of like webs like web
stuff or e-commerce you might have a lot
of big data if you're doing a lot of
streaming or like kind of like tech or
uh video stuff like that or with sensor
data you'll experience a lot of big data
but you know for like your general
generic like you know
your typical machine learning problems
generally won't revolve around big data
and um one of the problems with big data
is not just the machine learning part of
it but also like how we're going to
store it how are we going to query it
who's going to host it
you know what's the cost of storing it
and like what actual insights can we get
from this data um that are useful you
know
um oftentimes when i'm looking at um
problem machine learning problems or if
i want to think if i'm thinking about
using models for a project
i'm often not looking for the number of
samples in a data set but mostly the the
quality of the data in general
so that's another thing that we should
really kind of think about that
oftentimes if we have like three million
or four million samples it might not be
as good as like you know a 5 000 sample
data set with like great quality control
on it you know we have
nice and like the data is sanitary you
know people are putting in every all the
inputs um from like a
a reasonable standpoint so that's one
thing that we need to consider when
we're doing stuff with big data or even
thinking about doing stuff with with big
data is understanding kind of the source
of that um before we actually start
running an analysis
so we can kind of plot out our um
our model metric so we can see that the
degree of interaction
is one and that's slightly higher you
can see that it's almost like an
intercept or we're getting higher rrc
aoc performance um and we can see that
the number of terms have increased and
we can
uh be comfortable using five
so
we can do that show best five terms with
a product degree of one let's actually
look at this so we'll do five
one
and
one of the reasons why i'm not creating
a workflow
is that we wanna actually um do some
pre-processing
um with it
um that way we can actually look at this
in a database because oftentimes we
don't we're not going to be able to use
our pre-processing inside the database
so um let's actually fit it to our churn
data is equal to rec
prep
juice
and also use the vip package to do the
vip
right
so we can see the 10-year
internet service optic and payment
method check are the important uh
variables that we see right now
lastly we can actually do
a workflow just to evaluate on the test
set to see how it performs
um on
our test set or are there the data sets
that we haven't seen so add model
and i'll just copy this thing in right
here because that's the best parameters
i will add the recipe which is the red
and then we'll say last fits
i think we called it model splits and
we'll say collect metrics
right
so we can see our roc aoc is 0.80 i
think our original one was 0.83 so we
have
just a little bit less in the number of
terms
um but
um that's fine you know this is just
kind of an example so you know we're not
really working over
um like how to
tune a model since i've made plenty of
videos on how to do that but
now let's actually think about
say we have this model and you know it's
good we know that it's a pretty easy
model to build out because it's you know
using five terms
there's not a huge amount of
interactions we don't have a lot of
features that we're going to be using
so we can actually create this into a a
model or a sql query model um very
quickly
so when we have our fitted model right
here we can actually just pipe it in to
tidy predict and in this case we'll do
title predict sql
and then what we can do is
we can do the uh was a db plier
which is included in um d plier and we
can just simulate um whatever back-end
database we want um i think i'll just do
ms sql i think ms or notes mysql
um
so my sql is i think the most like
bare-bones sql you can use and right
there since we know that mars models are
just like kind of like spline models
um they're pretty easy to actually write
out or convert to
a
sql script so we can see right here
that's doing it um it's just a bunch of
case statements but let's actually see
that in practice by
creating a little database or a little
table and making our
using our query to actually
test the the model or the sql model so
we'll say db connect this from the dbi
package
uh i'll use r sql with it rc
full
um white
and then we'll say sql lights
and our db name
oops db name will be in memory
right
so we're just saying we're going to
create a table in memory that's going to
act as our database
and then what we'll do is we have our
data frame right here which is the one
that has no missing values but wasn't
like the training test split um we'll
actually do is a copy to
give it our connection and then our data
frame
and now we have our data frame as a
table into memory which is going to kind
of simulate
what it's like to be
uh oops what's going to simulate what
oh well it's going to simulate what
we're going to do for our database
so
i'm going to actually expand this up
and then we'll type in sql
connection is equal to con
and if we do a select star from
uh
df we can see our data frame is right
here
and it's fine and dandy
so if we look at this query right here
we can see that there's a few things
like it's saying payment method
electronic check and that's essentially
a dummy variable because if we look at
our variables that we're using from
right here it's tenure internet service
and payment method so let's actually do
that so let's say uh was it internet
service
and payment
method and
tenure we'll also select the customer id
that's our id and then we'll say also
churn
right
um
so we can see right here it's uh you
know
we need to do some manipulation to it
luckily that's pretty easy um it's just
a bunch of case statements so
you know this is where we can brush up
on our sql and do our little service
right here so we'll say
um with internet service
it's saying uh
fiber optic right fiber optic yep we'll
just do a case statement right there so
we'll say
case when
equals
fiber
optic
then one else zero and as
and we'll give it whatever the name is
for the internet service fiber
optic
and actually i think it might be
um let's see oh me
count
count oh yeah it's right there so fiber
optic so it has a little dot that'll
replace the uh um
the space
so we have that and then we'll also do
the payment method right so
base when
payment method
is equal to
um what's the payment method uh
payment method equals electronic check
so
electronic
check
then one else zero and as internet
service
uh where is it
and as a
payment method electronic check
oops
and we'll actually make that into a
little calm
we have that and finally we can just do
a little select star so select
from
or a little sub query we'll say select
from and we're going to be selecting
from this other query right here
um
i'll give it an a and then we'll copy
and paste this just to test it out
right so we have that and then we'll say
churn
rob
and we'll also select the customer id
okay so now we have the probability of
churn with our customer id
um
um using our sql model so i'm going to
call it say output.bar is equal to sql
red
now we have our sql pred
equal
red
and let's actually create our
um final model so we'll just say uh
where is it where is it
uh where is it oh there it is
so we'll fit that
right and then we'll also augment it to
our
whole data set
so we'll just say we'll use our recipe
to process our data
and we'll also bind our columns where
we'll select the
customer id
right and then we'll select the custom
customer id
and we'll select the uh
dot preview so dot pred
yes and we'll say this is the mars model
and we'll left join our sql pred
uh by
um
customer id
customer id
cool
and we'll rename to sql model is equal
to
turn
rob
so just a basic amount of data
manipulation but i want to kind of
highlight
um
i'm an example of sometimes the actual
model the sql model will be slightly off
so if we have our mars model
our sql model
gm
uh we'll just do a gm point
so what i want to do is plot the actual
direct comparisons so gm ab line which
will be our little
y equals x um line i'll also do the
chord equals observe versus pred
uh we'll see that this line or the
sql model
is not meeting it perfectly in fact you
can see that the slope of it is actually
pretty off
and that's the one kind of that's
actually a huge problem with you know
converting these mars or converting
these machine learning models into a sql
script is that you know we only have
case statements and stuff like that um
we can't get super fancy and sometimes
it doesn't uh translate uh perfectly
especially with like classification
models and stuff like that but
what we can do um is actually do a minor
adjustment to it
um also i think changing the back end so
in this case we're using like ms sql but
you can also change it to like i think i
mean we're using my sql but i think you
change like ms sql it'll actually kind
of fix it um so it depends on your back
end so
um you might not have to change anything
but it's also good to kind of make these
plots to compare
whether what your sql model is doing
with compared to your your true model or
your true like you know our model
but this is a very easy fix
um what we can actually do is that we
can select this
um and right here we can think like oh
hey we can just like change the slope of
it which is you know just a minor
adjustment just a linear regression
right
so let's do that so let's predict the
mars model probability using the sql
model and then we'll say
data is equal to dot
and then we'll augment it out
and then let's see the actual
adjustments so x equals mars model
y equals dot fitted
oops and then we'll say gm
point plus gm a b line plus chord obs
spread
and we can see that it's been adjusted
pretty well
so it's not perfectly one to one
but it's good enough right so you know
might have to do some more probability
calibration stuff like that but in
general this is a pretty quick model
that you know we can did we can do a
minor adjustment to it and do pretty
well
so what i'm going to do right here is
actually get the coefficients from it
and let's actually go into what we would
do to adjust our sql model query
i'm going to grab this
right
and i'm just going to kind of show off
some of my sequel that i know from like
school and stuff like that
so what we're going to do is do a with
statement so with
um
i will say uh dia de uh
data
as
and we'll select
this
and then we'll say model data as
and we'll select
that
and that'll be from df
uh from you don't have to do that
from from
data so i'm basically creating this sub
query right here and then i'm creating
another table that's going to be using
this created query so i'm creating a
query right here and then i'm using i'm
creating another table to query from
that query and then i'm going to do
just a sanity check so i'll say select
star from model data
all right so we have that and then
finally we can do like adjusted
red
as that's
and in this case we can select the model
data
all right so we'll say uh
churn prob
and then we'll also do a little
adjustment using these this linear
regression so plus churn uh plus so the
at the intercept
plus the
coefficient times churn prob
and we'll say as adjusted
rob and also do customer
id uh customer id
from churn pro
oh and then we'll do uh
select star from adjusted red
all right so now we have our adjusted
prop right there right
uh and we'll call this
output.var equals sql adjust
because why not
okay
now i have receivable adjust
and we do a little sani check right here
so we'll just uh
get this thing right there
right
and we'll left join
and we'll say by
customer id
and we'll pivot longer and this will do
the uh
actual do some renaming first just to
make it cleaner so rename
uh
old
i'll say non
non-adjusted
rob is equal to churn prob
and then we'll pivot that just make it
tiny or tidy so adjusted prob and then
adjusted prob
and finally we'll plot it out so
just do a quick gg pot
um point
right so then we do it ooh what's your
co y goals
value
what's going on here
uh let's see uh mars model
okay
and you can see how we came from this to
there so we just kind of spread it out
which we did a little minor adjustment
again nothing too crazy pretty fast
adjustment right there to make our model
you know the probabilities a little bit
uh more situated
for me personally i would probably just
run like a logistic regression and just
do a
you know adjust it through that instead
of doing a
um a a
linear regression
but you know it depends on your your
data and stuff like that but
that right there is a pretty quick way
of creating a quick model
uh putting into a query
and then you know evaluating the query
to see how well
the
the sql model uh is compared to the old
model
and then putting it into like a database
or giving it to some type of like sql
developer and scheduling it out
okay
so that is just you know that's not only
big data um i'm sure most of you guys
wanted to do big data stuff like how can
we actually fit a model using the cool
flashy things like hadoop and spark um
in database so we don't have to worry
about any of this stuff um luckily i
found
the sparkler website
so what we're going to do now is
actually create a you know a simulated
spark um like database i guess or
uh
is that a cluster
so we'll say sc spark connect
master equals local if you don't have
um sparkler installed you may need to
actually have this
and then right there so i just copy and
pasted that and there
which will install like an instance of
spark
um but
again it's pretty straightforward right
there
um okay
so in this case we're going to create
another thing we're going to create our
table
um in this case we have to do a turn
table and say copy to
sc and we'll give it our ds or df
and if we look at our turn table
it's a spark connection we can see our
little churn data set right there
and let's actually go and do some you
know data manipulation
or show you how to make like essentially
a a a pipeline for creating your you
know spark models so
right now with our turntable um i'm
gonna do a few things let's just do like
our i don't know like internet service
uh maybe i could do a
maybe i'll do this quickly
yeah let's actually do it okay so i'm
going to just do a brief um kind of like
a p-value approach to a gom so i'll say
um oops
train data
and we'll say uh
uh let's say a glm um
churn
data equals uh wreck crap
juice
fam oh family is binomial
and we'll tidy it
and then we'll say like filter like p
dot value
five so now we have our things right
there this is something we'll just do
uh you know i just felt like you know
we'll create a random forest model but
we use like a p value to do the uh like
uh
feature selection even though obviously
random force can do it for us um but
so what we want to do now is say what
are the things that we need to change
right so right now we have return table
um we want to do our contract year so
let's see what our contract year looks
like
um where is that at
contract so we'll say mutate we'll say
contract
uh
one year is equal to if else
so contract is equal to
uh one year
oops
one zero
so in this case what we have to do is
actually do like the dummy variables
itself i have looked at
oh i've looked at a little bit on like
the uh
the things that we can do so there's
like a binarizer a threshold to a calm
such that lesser equal
bucketizer um
it does cut but i'm not i don't think i
really saw a
a uh maybe there's a
dummy
thing but i see i feel like all these
are uh stop words and stuff like that so
um we'll just do it
um manually right now so we'll do our
one year we'll also do our
two year
so we'll copy that and say
true year so if it's equal to i guess
two year
okay so two year and then we'll do
paperless spilling so
paperless
yes
is equal if else and uh where's paper
was bowling at
um
what's it called
what what paperwork a paper was billing
oh there is paper was billing
is equal to yes one zero
and lastly we'll do i guess payment
method
so
a method is equal to or if else
payment i'll say we'll say payment
electronic payment electronic
so if else uh
payment method
is equal to
what's the electronic
check
we'll give it a one and zero
okay
and then um we'll have to select the
thing so
select uh churn
churn uh senior citizen
uh tenure
uh total charges
um
we got forgot multiple lines so we'll do
that again
uh we'll say
multiple lines yes
those if else
uh multiple lines
equals yes one zero
okay
cool
uh so we have our 10-year total charges
uh we'll do our multiple lines yes
our contract one
year contract
two year
uh paperless
and our payment method electronic
yay let's see what's going on here in
our pay method electronic oh right there
uh
okay let's see here
select
payment method
okay
oh there you go
okay so we have that which is
essentially
like the transformation that it's going
to do because this is very easy to
transform uh this like d player syntax
into like a sql thing so what i always
call is like we'll call it spark
the plier
right and what we can kind of see is we
can actually convert this transformation
or these like features stuff like that
into our transformer so we'll say our
source and we'll say our spark applier
and it kind of shows that right there
you know if we say ml param which is
like the upper functions
uh we can say statement
and we can see what it's doing where
it's creating the uh
that uh sql right there
okay so now let's actually go on to kind
of creating our model or our model
pipeline this essentially right here is
our recipe and now let's actually put it
together and create like a workflow so
we'll say ml pipeline
we'll give it our source
we'll say our uh
will fit our dpr transformer
and our table our our table i guess will
be our
this function right there
right there
and then we'll say fits our formula
and in this case i like to i just copy
this in
right there
give it a tilde and then we'll just do a
search and replace oops not that
a search so we'll say
that and we'll replace it with uh
that leave
cool
we have that right there
and then we can fit our model i believe
so we'll say ml
and then we say random forest classifier
and this will be our spark
we'll call it our churn
pipeline
and if we look at our churn pipeline
it kind of gives us a nice little like
uh
i guess workflow
it's a more complicated recipe of it but
that's our pipeline right there what we
can actually start doing is creating our
tests and training test splits um and
that's kind of useful because you know
why wouldn't you just query it do a
select star from the churn table and
then partition it like that
sometimes you know you can't store it in
memory in our laptops so oftentimes we
might want to put it into our database
so we'll call it our
spark split
and we'll say sdf
which is like our spark function and
then we do the random splits
we give it our turn
table which is turntable
uh we'll give it our training which is
which is 0.8 and our testing which is
0.2
and now we have our smart split our
spark split object
and it returns our train and test
tables
which is very nice
and finally we can fit our model so
we'll say our spark
model so we'll say ml
bits
give it our pipeline which is our model
you know our preprocessing our dpr
transformations the formula the model we
want to use
and then our data set so in this case we
often use our train data sets
right there
so now it's fitting the model
and finally we can actually go and make
our predictions on our test set so we'll
say spark
pred
and we'll say ml transform
which essentially is saying like hey we
have this
data set or table and we're going to
pass it to the pipeline and transform it
into our our thing that we want to get
out of it
so
we're going to give it our spark model
and then our spark
split
with our testing data set
and now we have it
so what i would want to do is select the
probably customer id
uh
what was it customer
um what was it called
it's uh
yeah we'll just look at it
all right
uh okay so it's gonna pop up
see it actually takes a little bit uh
because there's a lot of stuff that goes
into it but we have our churn so we'll
say
uh we'll select our
earn
um
and then our
probability
did i not put the uh
oh yeah oops
oh well
right turntable or trencher will shove
it right
oh yeah i forgot to add the customer id
into this so obviously i want to put
this right there
that way it'll keep this the customer id
in there
so we'll just do that again
which is fine
all right so we do that
right because like when we're passing in
our spark our deep wire thing right here
um we didn't select customer id uh we'll
do something that's probably useful
which is why we have like our
transformation which is like our select
statements and then our formula where we
can like basically not put in our
customer id because that can cause some
problems um did i pass the yup transform
so we can look at that
and then we'll probably do a customer
id
yep so we have our customer id
oops
customer id and then lastly we'll use
collect which is going to basically do
the actual query so we'll say like
i'll call it uh i don't res
right so res so that way we're basically
saying like predict on uh given our
given prediction we're gonna actually
query it and get the results as a data
frame in memory
and ooh actually i forgot to select the
uh prediction so let me do the
prediction
right so we can see how we have our
churn
our result our customer id and then the
probability of it being churned
and then
the actual probability
gives it in like uh turn or no churn so
we can say map
dbl
uh probability
and it's a pluck
uh was it
two right
and right here we can see that we have
the probability of churn since the
prediction is one we see that's above 50
percent that means it's like
uh yes the probability of it act of a
churn probably no turn it's a low
probability and stuff like that
so yeah
um as you can see it's actually very
easy to create
um your your models in spark um given
this type of memory data set so
oftentimes you'll have to do a bunch of
joins and stuff like that um i'm not
gonna go over deployment because i i
don't know how you would do it um with
like your given system you probably have
to save the file and stuff like that but
what's really nice about these types of
pipelines right here is that you can
just run it on anything you can put it
you know probably
um on your setup
you can refit it pretty easily you can
just save this pipeline and then then
just fit it to whatever data set you
have or from maybe even a refresh table
so you like schedule that like off hours
and stuff like that um so again
it's very straightforward package i
personally really like using the uh tidy
predict it's very fast and you can kind
of make adjustments um it's also very
useful when you want to do like a you
know a taboo dashboard and stuff like
that
so
um yeah this will conclude the thai
tuesday series um i really enjoyed
making these videos
um the main reason why i'm not making
more videos or not making more like
regular scheduled videos is because i
think i've kind of hit my ending where
i've taught everything i wanted to teach
this was basically the last thing i
wanted to teach um
and uh i figured i would kind of not
overstay my
my stay on to youtube
but i really hope you guys enjoyed all
my videos i'm still going to be kind of
active i want to do more project related
videos but that won't be at a consistent
schedule
um
so with that being said
um i hope you guys had fun with my
youtube channel and teddy on